maybe 23 means more whack ancestry.com
might be more like maybe 23 and me it's
like the Samsung of life I'm assuming
based on what I got I don't think I'm
gonna get any of the variety that you
have he got like 12 orange chicken
broccoli you are my team or not double
got a little bit Mongolian three percent
sweet and sour sauce
[Music]
welcome back to another
careful boys today we have Nick and
Colleen over there we got Joe and
Anthony over here and today everybody we
are going to meet Joseph
thanks for being here man appreciate it
you're Colleen's friend yeah
[Laughter]
what's going on dude yeah yeah she's
pretty cool you know I always say uh
every time I meet uh someone or she's
the first person I met in La so oh cool
where are you from that's a good first
person I'm from Northern California San
Jose to be exactly San Jose with the
Vietnamese people man you know a lot of
people yes yeah
School Independence High Schools where I
went and I grew up around a whole bunch
of Asians so oh yeah I kind of feel at
home right
here I never feel at home here you
shouldn't I know we do that on purpose
we want to make sure you don't except
when Steve's here I feel like there's
some relatability they're always
whispering in the corner dude plotting
some white conspiracy yeah they're doing
something
what what so are you what are you
ethnically because that's not important
to us it was just more of an interview
question that the fans always ask so if
you want uh what I was told when I was
growing up I was just told that I was
black Mexican French Cherokee Indian
whoa wow Cherokee Indian wow sick you
own a casino huh no no I don't own any
casinos unfortunately have you ever done
a 23 mirror that's when you should do it
would you ever do that
I don't know then why'd you specify what
you were told it's like you got like a
developing well because when I was in uh
then I ended up going to the military
right and uh we're always celebrating
like different holidays and stuff like
that so me being you know Mexican and
I'll celebrate Cinco de Mayo and you
being black celebrating you know black
history you get to do every single song
exactly so my friends got tired of me
like trying to sit here and claim all
these they're like you know we need to
figure out what the hell you are
you know they got me An ancestry DNA
test for my birthday and I actually took
one of those I was able to see like my
home list of like I'm like 33.4 Chinese
now I don't believe it dude it keeps
changing the sauce went up I can see it
in your head sometimes the records are
all broken so who knows Yeah the more
you take the test yeah yeah it's gonna
be like this today yeah yeah
they'll even take
from you I was Korean and they took that
away from no actually yeah
they actually did that I feel like the
more they did
they do the call they wanted a back
way to add I think yeah
I can actually show you guys oh yeah
let's go through the list I've been
having a lot of conversations with
people about their ancestry recently
yeah and they're 23. this is interesting
though you can finally test like that
that's why that's it's a waste of money
for the Asian one because it's all
boring yeah bro I got hella
Asians get mad when they get like all
Chinese and I watch all the videos of
people saying not to do it and I still
did it I don't know why are they mad
yeah they say like they could like track
your DNA and stuff like that and I'm
just like they can get me in trouble for
future crimes all right you know for
future
just in case good movie I mean it'll
probably hard for you if you came back
100 Chinese yeah
I just look like everyone else dude
easier to hide yeah
it was 99 and then I looked the other
day it's a full hundred not Nick's like
90 Chinese 10 so that's why mine went up
but you know what's pretty interesting
yeah
you're like the last generation of 100
Chinese because then now you're next of
kin yeah they're gonna be halfers yeah
it's gonna be 50 poop is US
my wife's gonna be producing strictly
Chinese kids though
say what you were told first one more
time remind us before you did this uh
ancestry thing so I started all the
black Mexican French and check the
Indian okay do they give you like a
sick like what you were most like your
grandma was Cherokee or oh that's weird
I know I said she did that well my my so
my dad's side he's uh Creo which is a
black and French and then my mom's side
she's uh yep from Louisiana and then uh
my mom saw she's Mexican Chucky
from Louisiana
that sounds like California
that makes sense it all adds up so top
one it says 20 uh Cameroon
so it's Cameroon Congo and Western Bantu
people so that's 20 and then it's 17
Nigerian
this is new oh
come on
baby he's a little Chinese brother
[Laughter]
it's like six percent San Jose
oh what's the new thing oh it said uh 11
Ireland
whoa they just oh
an Irish lad you don't see
you went from you were French but now
you're Irish
I I guess so damn dude see but this I'm
telling you this seems to be updating
all the time yeah
I'll check it out
it's changing all the time I'll do an
update yeah we'll do update and a date
so did you did you grow up in San Jose
your whole life uh yeah I grew up in San
Jose
um definitely enjoyed it there
um
and then once I once my um friends went
to like college and stuff like that I
ended up joining the military and that's
when I entered and you went to you said
you went to Marines yeah yeah I went to
the Marines I was in the Marine Corps
for 10 years 10 years too bad Bart's not
here
wait my math serves me at only 48 so far
what's the rest yeah
it was
uh Bantu or Cameroon it was Nigerian
Irish
uh so we have Molly
it's a nine percent Molly Molly that's
in Africa oh okay damn joke you
definitely get to like eight percent
Senegal dang uh seven percent Spain
wow
yeah I'm pretty it's bouncing back and
forth from European to Black you're
exotic I was expecting something you
didn't get like Hoon on and like all
these like different I was expecting
something that's right so you did this
too though I did 23 and Me Maybe 23
means more whack ancestry.com might be
more like maybe 23 and me it's like the
Samsung of life it might be the Android
version it might be the green bubble but
I'm assuming based on what I got I don't
think I'm gonna get any of the variety
that you have he got like 12 orange
chicken broccoli
outside
[Music]
I don't sound like that dude yo that
would be hella funny you want combo
three tell me
half price we just send you a menu from
some random ass Chinese restaurant 12
combo number three you're like oh
what's coming over here is that
everything that you exotic
all right I'm telling you the list goes
on and it says
you're making a mess four percent
dramatic European history was a PDF
wonder
you feel the page this is a headliner
see how much how much he's growing he
doesn't even get him you know what mine
was it was like this it was like
I was like oh yeah they should
differentiate because y'all mean Chinese
and Nick Chinese look pretty different
no I think they're pretty alike
Yao Ming is like 12 Chinese in like 88
dude I'm not sure dude Colleen you read
this out you
used to the piece
Chinese
no it says a Chinese Southern Chinese so
I'm 99
I'm 99 East Asian okay 99.9 yeah but
you're 100 Nicholas done that's cool
so Chinese and Southern Chinese can I
can I see you yeah you're gonna hand it
back right away so I'll just move my
hand
how is it he's like why are you so basic
he's like damn this sucks so you're not
considering doing 23andMe I'm not a
brand ambassador I promise I don't work
for him uh I mean no you should yeah you
have that yeah I have this it makes me
want to do 20 I think you should try it
I want to try ancestry you might as well
man is there something that you identify
with most culturally uh black there it
is nice sense what can the Mexicans do
to win you over yeah
okay that's a big win I love Mexican
food we had some yesterday it's pretty
good it was a good time well yesterday's
not today so let's focus on your 10
years in the Marine yeah what was that
like man what a transition huh yeah
um good 10 years so I went in so all my
friends like I said earlier they uh they
went off to college and then
what was that I couldn't even see from
Japan it's blood red yeah baby 99.9
they took your Korean away for real they
took my Korean away I had one I had one
percent career what is what is 99.9
Japanese and then 0.01 unassigned what
are they doing just they have to do that
insurance
yeah they can't give you a hundred
percent he's as authentic as it gets
yeah I'm sad congrats man it says oh
dude they put it down to Regions yeah it
says feudal region look you see the they
do that hey they do that region yeah I
got regions that's new
yeah
I'm rich in regions low-key though a
little bit of Taiwan
what little no it's not Taiwan
it's just naming the different countries
around you he just he just read the math
that's all that'd be like oh you're also
a little bit of China oh that's Asia
it's this Indian Ocean
that's cool
I'm just trying to be a little unique
you know
99 Japanese is pretty unique in this day
and age yeah it's hard to come by yeah
yeah there's not too many Japanese
people left you're gonna make hoppers
dude well they need to hurry up and let
other people in the country and mix up
yeah I feel like you're a rare breed
yeah you're a rare breed yeah but I'm
already screwing that up so oh that's
true yeah hey y'all he's talking about
his white chick
he's mixed in races she's she's kind of
uh indigenous white too because she's
Welsh they're like Braveheart but like
on the southern part not the northern
part
isn't Welsh northern southern okay well
it is northern northern Europe we're
really good at geography here so that 10
years in the Marines yeah speaking of
good transition yeah uh so yeah 10 years
in the Marines
um I
where I got into it was uh one of my
boys was uh he came we met up one day
and he was like yeah I'm thinking about
going to the military I was like oh why
don't you uh join the Marine Corps and
then uh I just knew some people that
were you know cool in the Marines they
were the only ones that didn't like
Hackle me all the time and be like oh
hey you want to join you want to join
you know Army would come to my school
Air Force and stuff like that they'd
just chase you all the time
and so far checks out with Bart's story
because it's stories he went to the
recruitment center and then he saw the
marine guy sleep and he goes oh this guy
doesn't give a all right I'm
joking that's kind of how it is like
they asked me one time and then they
left it alone but what they did do was
with uh my basketball team would play
um at the park all the time so they
would come Run games with us all the
time don't even ask us to join and then
uh they invite us to go paintballing and
stuff like that and we go oh they did
the one and down the right way yeah yeah
and then uh
and then once my boy said that he was
gonna go to the military and I was like
oh why don't you just go to the Marines
you know they seem pretty dope and if
you go I'll go with you and then he
ended up uh getting signed up and then
we ended up shipping out like two weeks
afterwards holy to boot camp yeah
and then after that you just decided to
be active or so you uh so I went in
obviously for that like the first four
years you're starting your contract for
I was stationed in
um Camp Pendleton was my first Duty
station
and oh so you didn't have to go far no
no I didn't have to go far at all I
loved it best news station ever you know
I get to party in San Diego get to go
out you're right next to the little
nuclear boobs by the beach
that's the best part I've never heard
someone refer to them as that but now
that he says
that's a selling point as a kid I would
drive by in the car and I'd be like
that's boo
ironic it's right next to the water too
I know
let's focus Nick but uh yeah so um I did
I got stationed at Camp um Pendleton and
then
um I want to say three years in
I uh
uh was able to go on an individual
augment so I was basically able to
attach to another unit
um to go under deployment uh that's one
thing I've always wanted to do just get
that experience
um so I went to Afghanistan for a year
came back one piece thank god
um lost one person out there God Rest
his soul
um but uh ended up coming back everyone
else fine and then
um got stationed back at uh Camp
Pendleton again and then once I got
promoted I shipped over to
um
North Carolina and uh what would you get
promoted to I got promoted to E6
um I don't know what the that is
sorry my bad staff sergeant uh got
promoted to that and then you know they
were like yeah you got to go over to the
east coast
um my cruise I don't know I've a lot of
people say like oh I forget his military
stuff like that or I hated uh being in
the Marines and I feel like a lot of the
grunts say that just because I felt like
they're dealt some of the shittiest
cards
they have like the you know they're
always out there in the field and
training and stuff like that and then
you get you know people like me that
work in Supply we get a nice little
office and you know everybody wants to
eat cool with Supply because they got
all the the dope stuff
you know we get the bargain and stuff
was that something that you knew going
in like oh supply has the best yeah
actually my recruiter actually shout out
to my recruiter he was amazing because
he set me up with like the perfect job
that's cool
all the that fell off the back of
the truck
guys
you are 100 Japanese
but yeah I did a fine Logistics in the
military
um I started off doing uh procurements
when I first came in so that's basically
just dealing with everything
um
uh
that the I mean I'm stuttering right now
my bad it comes with the everything that
the unit needs to carry on with their
mission we're the ones to order it and
um just make sure it gets there in a
like timely manner
um so but you're pretty much purchasing
things from like anywhere I could buy
stuff from like a Walmart I could buy
stuff from like eBay Amazon anywhere
online
um so it's not just like weapons and
tactical stuff it's like cigarettes and
Playboys you're buying Playboys for the
squad yeah
it would be it would be some sketch
stuff people would be putting on their
on their things that were like sketches
it's just like oh yeah we need these big
flat screen TVs to go in this office and
it's just like bro what you need big
flat screen TVs for like you're here to
just do a meeting and that's it no no we
need we needed to do this we need to
have this type of setup oh yeah let's
see let's get an Xbox for the common
room and stuff like that was like bro no
we don't we don't need we need to we
need to practice our drills but we're
playing Call of Duty so we're practicing
on the field and off off the field in
our living so you really had the power
to say yes or no to these things yeah
yeah and I had it at a very young age
which was freaking amazing what kind of
things do people do to try to get on
your good side oh then they just they're
just like oh yeah hey we can uh I worked
in a helicopter are they like Joseph you
look good today
I love that shirt
just learning Bro you've been working
out yo did you just get a haircut you
got a taller it's a little knock before
they enter the room hey what's up
San Jose
try to get out of the good side that was
actually a pretty good one like if I
could relate anymore from like the Bay
Area yeah oh yeah you're getting hooked
up inside two Xbox
no controller
coming in my Cherokee Indian bro
[Laughter]
what the hell yeah
so I did that my first couple of years
uh and then I switched over to uh this
thing called cmrs it's a Consolidated
memorandum report and it's basically all
the coolest names dude they got the
coolest names
a lot of syllables we're big on acronyms
yeah yeah really big on actors
um but yeah so I did that and that's
basically keeping track of all like uh
headquartered Marine Corps assets that
come into your unit
um that makes it operable and they're
able to carry out their trainings and
stuff like that so you got to just make
sure you're keeping track of everything
um it covers like laptops TVs radios
anything with a serial number
um you're keeping track of
um well I did a good do a good job
keeping track of it because a lot of it
got lost Mark fears anybody dude that's
all I know got lost yeah what's the
sickest post-service benefits that you
receive post-service benefits
um
say free medical that's cool oh yeah
that is uh in this country yeah yeah
that's cool wow I am 90 disabled oh 90
yeah I've had a lot of surgeries I've
had uh niece nerve damage in my left leg
so I can't like stand on my left tiptoe
um I have a three inch screw that's
holding my heel in place whoa um
um I've had two shoulder surgeries on
this one and I've had one on this one is
this like from service or were you
already up and then you signed up
because you knew
[Laughter]
good question good question he's too
smart he's from paintball when they went
from the pickup games
I'd be afraid if he went into the
military because he he'd definitely be
trying to cheat yeah
[Music]
built away for a reason yeah
see you see his warding too yeah very
careful get on paperwork but uh again
your question was the injuries the
injuries
in service so um no so I ended up
getting
um someone I was born I had like a tumor
in my lower back that was messing with
my spinal cord wasn't supposed to be
able to walk
um so they ended up doing a back surgery
removed the tumor and stuff like that
when I was 12 tumor grew back again
messing with my spinal cord went back in
removed all the Skyrim t-shirt
everything was good
um before you go into
um
the military you have to do like a
full-on physical I was 100 they would
stand on both my tiptoes do everything
um and then when I joined the military
that's when I started even like getting
all like the problems and complications
oh so it happens while I was saying
like as a result of like your training
and things that you had to do or you're
playing Xbox and he was like oh for my
shoulder
now my shoulder actually was pretty bad
like it got to a point where I had to
like reach underneath the desk to go
grab my shoes to go out or something
like that and then my shoulder line just
popped out of sockets
[Music]
oh man
but uh but yeah so I had like two back
surgeries before uh the military and
then when I got in the military that's
when I had
through back
it's what five
two three
so damn that those surgeries
seven then you use them credits man yeah
man
I've never even had a surgery before
never ever
yeah that's crazy yeah wait that's right
you're uncircumcised
hit the weasel
all right we're gonna continue with part
two we're gonna continue with Joseph's
story after this on what happened and
why he chose to cap it at the tenure and
then where he went after the military so
stay tuned for that
thank you